hello there I'm dr. Michael hunt but
everyone just calls me Mike and I'm the
chief medical officer here at the
pokemon gold rehabilitation center do
you or someone you love suffer from both
[ __ ] addiction are you obsessed with
what is essentially virtual cockfighting
if so here at the pokemon gold
Rehabilitation Center we can help you
this is Jimmy
his friends brought him to the pokemon
gold rehabilitation center because
pokemon gold was ruining his life now we
are readjusting him to the real world by
helping him to interact with real nature
instead of virtual nature
oh it's Professor Oak no Jimmy I'm not
professor old we've been I made it I
mean professor willow clearly it's
working so that's why you're a friend
Jimmy
Jimmy Jim is a cool cat used to be
he usually one-of-a-kind used to play
supports very active in the community
girlfriend everything and then Pokemon
go happened that's when everything
changed
Jimmy changed now here's a classic
example of Pokemon go addiction
Jimmy currently thinks he's lagging like
his character in the game in order to
address this issue we have to be very
delicate this is not game Jimmy this
isn't a game this is real life
you told us before off-camera that won't
my goal made Jimmy violent what did you
mean by that last night I heard Jimmy he
was part of a gang actually one of the
one of the top members at this point I'm
guessing like I said man he's not at all
he's not the same person
he's just normally just see him just not
the same whatsoever but yeah he got
involved in some violence I guess gang
violence gang activity oh yeah we want
female
oh hey guys are you playing on over to
Jim after we leave in the final stages
or program we are reintroducing Jimmy to
the real world and teaching him how to
interact with nature and with real
animals like this small dog here Jimmy
oh man I'll have this one yet no Jimmy
this is not a Pokemon this is a real
animal don't don't try to curveball that
Jimmy just here pet pet the dog what a
way to gain better there you go as you
can see it's working our program is very
effective and Jimmy is once again
becoming a productive member of our
society don't get too excited there
Jimmy hi my name is Morgan Freeman and
I'm living proof that Mike hunt can work
miracles on anybody even you now prior
to seeing Mike I I was a mess I was
rarely home I'd be pitching tents
outside of gym so that no one else could
take them I'd be spending what little
money I did have on lures and incense
cost me my job my marriage even got a
team instinct tattoo on my thigh but
then when I thought all hope was lost
and I was just in way too deep Mike hunt
stepped in and pulled me out he showed
me that I had a problem it was ruining
my life and that I needed to let
pokemons go and over the course of 257
one-on-one talks and 5 electric shock
therapy sessions
he got me unhooked so if you feel like
your Pokemon go addiction is just too
much for anyone to handle remember
nothing is too big for Mike hunt
at the pokemon gold rehabilitation
center we're here to help and together
we can let Pokemon go let Pokemon go hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
so much we hope you liked the skit and
if you did please give us a thumbs up
and click that subscribe button we would
really appreciate that we just want to
say that we have a lot of fun with this
of course our intention wasn't to poke
fun at substance abuse or any serious
issues like that this was just the kind
of poke fun and uh those are our friends
that we know are taking Pokemon go a
little bit too far and thanks to all our
friends for helping us with this kit can
both a big thanks to Matt will not
please check out his youtube channel
he's a hilarious animated own gaming out
Cooper and you know we really liked
working with him he's an awesome guy and
yeah thanks guys for subscribing for
commenting for taking the time out of
your day to be a part of our channel it
means so much to us and we hope to grow
this community in the years to come
thanks again see you soon more to come
peace